in this lesson we're going to talk about
biotin the structure is shown right here
biotin is also called vitamin b7 it acts
as a coenzyme in the body which means
biotin can bind to an enzyme and enable
that enzyme to do chemistry that it
wouldn't be able to do on its own this
coenzyme enables an enzyme to add co2 to
a molecule it enables carboxylation to
begin this process biotin must first
become linked to a lysine residue on the
enzyme and it'll link up right here
however this carboxyl a at biological
pH at pH seven point four is going to be
deprotonated and it's going to be in
this anionic form so it's really
difficult for a nucleophile a lysine
residue to come in and just attack this
carboxylate so biotin gets activated
first it undergoes a reaction with ATP
in this reaction biotin is going to
become bound to this entire piece of the
molecule so this carboxylate will attack
this phosphorus atom kicking off
pyrophosphate which is two phosphate
groups linked together so we can show
our first arrow making the bond to
phosphorus and then we'll kick off
pyrophosphate as a leaving group and now
our carboxylate has formed an anhydride
linkage and it has the whole am p piece
attached the carbonyl of this anhydride
is much more easily attacked now by a
lysine on the enzyme because this is a
great leaving group let's look at that
process now here's our enzyme bound
lysine it's easier to show the mechanism
in one step when the lysine side chain
is not charged let's bring in a basic
amino acid residue to deprotonate lysine
while a lone pair on nitrogen attacks at
this carbonyl so this attack is
facilitated by a basic amino acid
residue which removes a
from the lysine and we can show the
electrons from this bond that are left
behind making the new bond to this
carbonyl this will form a tetrahedral
intermediate pushing the electrons up
onto oxygen they'll swing back down and
I'm going to use a biochemical shorthand
to just show the bond breaking to the a
MP group so these two arrows represent a
shorthand of two distinct steps the
first where the nitrogen attacks here
and these electrons push up onto oxygen
forming a tetrahedral intermediate in
the second step the electrons swing back
down and kick off this group but this is
a perfectly acceptable abbreviation for
that now biotin is linked to the enzyme
in an amide linkage here and this enzyme
is said to be biotin elated now the
biotin is going to react in such a way
that a co 2 group is transferred onto
this nitrogen and then can be
transferred on to another molecule I'm
going to draw an abbreviated structure
of biotin and let's walk through that
process the process of introducing the
co 2 group onto this nitrogen is going
to begin by an enzyme residue a basic
enzyme residue deprotonating this
hydrogen atom here but this molecule
isn't very acidic I don't know the pKa
of biotin but urea which is just this
here with NH 2 groups on either side so
we need to add a group onto each
nitrogen here that has a pKa of 26.9
which really isn't very acidic but in
the active site other enzyme residues
can be carefully positioned to
facilitate this proton becoming more
acidic and so we're actually going to
have a positively charged lysine residue
hanging out with this carbonyl here the
interaction of the carbonyl oxygen with
this positively charged nitrogen is
going to make this hydrogen atom much
more acidic now a nearby basic enzyme
residue can deprotonate this hydro
Adam and we can push electrons all the
way up until we get an ion pair between
the lysine and this oxygen atom
so our lysine is still up here
positively-charged
this enzyme residue now has a proton on
it from biotin and let's draw what
biotin looks like we're adding a double
bond here and pushing these electrons up
on to oxygen and now this nitrogen is
ready to attack a molecule of co2 these
electrons can swing down and this can
grab the co2 molecule but it's not quite
that simple
we don't just trap co2 gas inside the
cell in fact co2 gas will react with
water and form the molecule bicarbonate
so bicarbonate needs to be trapped in
some way and let's look at that step now
so this is how bicarbonate is going to
look in the body at pH 7 point 4 we have
this one o H group deprotonated so we
have this anion it actually looks a lot
like this and remember we couldn't just
attack this directly with lysine we
needed to activate it in some way and
here we used ATP and with bicarbonate
again we're going to use ATP to make
this carbonyl more reactive but it's
going to react in a slightly different
way this time this group will attach to
the terminal phosphate so here I'm
abbreviating this adp is all of this
part of the molecule right here through
this second phosphate I have the oxygen
atom drawn out so I can show my arrow
pushing and then this phosphate group
corresponds to this phosphate group here
in this reaction we're going to attack
the terminal phosphate kicking off adp
since this is a carboxylic acid this
will become ionized become negatively
charged at physiological pH so we're
going to lose this proton it may be that
an enzyme residue comes in and grabs the
proton but it might also be that this
deprotonate spontaneously and the body
can just accept the H+ in a buffered
system so since we don't know how that
happens I'm just gonna write minus h
plus and show
we get so representing the loss of a
proton this way and now the enzyme
that's bound to are activated biotin
here can bind our phosphorylated
bicarbonate and this will become
attached the mechanism may occur in one
of two ways perhaps these electrons push
in and this kicks off and a co2 molecule
is produced in close proximity to this
nitrogen atom but I'm going to show you
another way that we can also show the
arrow pushing where we're going to push
down through this system and attack
directly at this species here instead of
producing a small amount of co2 very
close in the active site however both
mechanisms are plausible the electrons
on oxygen will push down the double bond
from this carbon to nitrogen can swing
out now the electrons from this carbon
oxygen double bond push up to make a
tetrahedral intermediate swing back down
and kick off a molecule of inorganic
phosphate inorganic phosphate in the
body has one proton on it and so as this
is leaving we can use an acidic enzyme
residue to make sure this leaves in its
correct protonation state we still need
to link up these two pieces of the
molecule so I'll redraw that down here
and we'll continue on with our third
step which will be the transfer of co2
to a substrate in gluconeogenesis biotin
transfers a carboxyl group to pyruvate
to form oxaloacetate so let's look at
this step of gluconeogenesis
here's pyruvate i'm going to draw out
the hydrogen atoms on this carbon being
adjacent to a carbonyl group these
hydrogen atoms are acidic and they can
be removed and an enolate can be formed
a deprotonated cysteine residue a
thiolate in the active site can
deprotonate one of the alpha hydrogen
atoms and an enol a is produced now we
can show our arrow pushing where these
electrons swing down the enol a attacks
at this carbon and we cleave the co2
of biotin alternatively we can show our
arrow pushing so that we produce a
molecule of co2 in close proximity to
our enol a of pyruvate and it gets
attacked I'm gonna draw our molecule of
co2 right here I'll draw it in purple so
that it isn't lost between our two blue
structures that are quite close now our
arrow pushing will look like this and we
produce a molecule of oxaloacetate to
sum up biotin is a coenzyme an enzyme
helper that allows for the carboxylation
of enolates
biotin needs to be activated to be
linked up to a lysine residue on an
enzyme covalently this activation occurs
with ATP and forms an intermediate
biotin first needs to be deprotonated to
act as a nucleophile and the enzyme
active site can facilitate that process
bicarbonate is the source of co2 in
these reactions it first becomes
activated by reacting with ATP linking
up with the phosphate and then biotin
can attack it producing a molecule of
inorganic phosphate and our carboxylated
biotin enolization of a substrate allows
for that substrate to become a
nucleophile trapping the co2 produced
from biotin and introducing a co2 group
on to the substrate